as an entrepreneur staying motivated is
one of the hardest things that there is
you got to get up every day go to work
pound on your crap get better make
continual progress towards your goals
and achieving your dreams but it's hard
because a lot of times you're doing this
all on your own and you may be on fire
one day have lots of great progress land
a new deal and then the next thing you
wake up and you're starting from scratch
and you've lost all that energy and
you're wondering where it went so today
I'm going to share with you seven ways
to beat procrastination and get work
done
number one is create a supportive
environment the environment that you
surround yourself in is gonna be
reflection of the person who you are and
the person who you will become
so if you're surrounded by mediocrity
right if you're working out of some
basement apartment is nothing in there
that inspires you how do you expect to
create great things so start your day
with music that gets you excited
surround yourself with friends that
build you up and support you watch
youtube videos that give you motivation
strategies make you want to be better
put yourself in an environment that
builds you up to get too excited so when
you go to start working you're you're
proud of where you are put posters up on
the wall that have meaningful quotes to
you remind yourself of what your goals
are create an environment that when you
step into it you're ready to go to work
build that supportive environment number
two is have a big why you've got to have
a reason for doing this if you're in
business just trying to make money it's
not gonna happen you have to have a big
goal you look at entrepreneurship
success the big ones the guns gun make
tons of money it's never money that's
their goal it's they want to have an
impact somehow you have to have that big
wire that driving force I look at Oprah
Winfrey and when she started her talk
show she came off of that first episode
and she felt like she was breathing for
the first time and she said that she
would find ways to make ends meet just
to continue to do this because she loved
it so much that's how you know when
you're doing the right thing when you
have that much passionate you could pour
into it you have this
overarching goal this big wide that
you're gonna shoot for it has to be
there if it's not if you don't know why
you're doing this if you did it just
just kind of make enough money to pay
your mortgage and pay the bills it's not
a big enough reason and your business
won't have big success so have that big
wide that when you look at it you get
inspired motivated excited ready to go
to work number three is have little
why's have little reasons that give you
constant inspiration motivation to get
to work for me it's you guys it's the
YouTube comments I wake up every day one
of the first things I do is go check out
my youtube comments you guys give me
energy and fuel and excitement and it
takes up a huge chunk of my time every
day going through the social media
comments but I love it because I know
that the stuff that I'm doing is having
an impact and yes my goal is to help a
billion entrepreneurs that's my big why
back to the last point but helping one
person who leaves a comment and said
that beauty you made really helped me
that drives me to want to keep going and
before I had that I made a PowerPoint
file of people who would listen to me at
presentations and seminars they left
their comments to me and I would put it
together in a PowerPoint file and watch
that every morning you need to have that
fuel so if customers are writing in to
you or people who you've helped are
writing to you or somebody's left a
voicemail for you whatever to save that
stuff and look at it those are your
little why's the fact that you help that
one person is fuel and energy to help
you go out and do that again and again
and again and continue to pour it into
your business because you're making an
impact
number four is commit to somebody when
you commit to somebody else to work on
something it's not only more fun but
you're more likely to get it done you're
more likely to get all the tasks done
because now you're accountable now that
person is gonna ask you what's going on
with this project but working in a team
also gives it a lot more creativity fun
energy because you can feed off other
people instead of just doing everything
yourself Jason I want Jason in here
we're gonna put Jason on the spot
Jason Fonseca empire builder to the room
please
yo yo let's get in here there we go this
is Jason
he helps entrepreneurs build empires
Jason now comes over every morning
pretty much at 9:30 to help me build my
Empire and as a result of working
together in close proximity we get a lot
more momentum energy creativity it's
amazing it's amazing we're getting stuff
done the procrastination does not exist
here because of the collaboration
together and as a side note I don't know
if Jason knows this I've been kind of on
and off with my workout routine and what
didn't know this is surprising surprise
for Jason on and off and and now I know
Jason's coming at 9:30 so I got to get
it done before that right so it's like
8:30 okay start pumping some weight it's
got to get it done get the shower
Jason's buzzing up I love and it comes
in so Jason is not only helping that
business get strong he's helping you get
me get strong that's rise up commit to
other people
number five is do something you love you
have to do stuff work that you love if
you are not excited by it if you are not
happy diving into your business how do
you expect to be motivated right if
you're looking at your list of tastic oh
I got a call that guy I got to do these
tasks I got to do XYZ you're not gonna
be motivated you're gonna dread it
you're gonna put it off as long as you
can so you want to put yourself in the
position where you're doing work that
you love and eliminate automate delegate
the rest of the way so you can focus on
what you're really good at where you add
the most value to the world that and
focus as much as your time possible on
that because it will help beat the
procrastination bug number six is
creative routine it's helpful to have a
daily or weekly a monthly routine that
gets you set up for success so for me
for example I know Wednesday's is my
video date today's Wednesday at least
when I'm filming it I don't know when
it's coming out but I record all my
videos on Wednesday and that's my
routine I set aside a big chunk of time
say videos are important to my business
I love answering questions I love
helping entrepreneurs I want to make
more videos like this and so I chunk off
huge chunk of time every Wednesday and
it's part of my routine so if the things
that you have to get done if big
projects you want to work on create a
routine that serves you find a day in
the week or a time every day and a lot
that the folk is saying only on that
project and not getting distracted by
everything else around you don't get
distracted by the fires building no
crisis business so that you're not just
reacting to things all the time but
you're proactively spending your time on
the big picture things and I help grow
your business and number seven is join a
mastermind group one of my favorite
experiences every month is I have a
mastermind group that we have Toronto
entrepreneurs you come together and we
meet to talk about our businesses and we
try to help each other grow and it's
it's both the combination of one getting
strategies and ideas and hey here's a
problem that I'm going through what do
you guys think about it how can you help
me to is also the motivation right to
see other entrepreneurs that are
struggling or that have struggling and
are achieving success and knowing that
you're not alone helps helps you breast
bust through helps you feel like you're
not alone anymore like other people have
these problems that you can share with
and a good mastermind group will also
have some accountability built in so for
us everybody has a year-round goal that
they're shooting towards by the end of
the year I have this numeric goal that
I'm shooting towards some people pick
revenue some people pick something else
that's meaningful but it's not you know
I want to feel happy about my life it's
always something quantifiable every
month we come back and update that
number on top of that we have monthly
goals so here's what I'm gonna get done
in the next month here's gonna get done
in the next month and you update the
group on how you're doing and people get
to know you and people get to discover
your tendencies and hopefully a good
group will do is hold your feet to the
fire you said hey you've been saying
you're gonna do this to last three
months what's going on man get to work
and having that external force that kind
of forced you to do something and make
you realize that this is an important
goal for yourself and you're not acting
on it it's helpful because entrepreneurs
we don't have bosses right you don't
have a boss you are your own boss so
you're going to focus on the projects
that you want to do and not necessarily
the ones that you're afraid of but that
you need to do to grow yourself and grow
your business so in summary this
ways to beat procrastination and get
work done number one creative supportive
environment number two have a big why
number three have little why's number
four commit to someone number five do
something you love number six have a
routine and number seven join a
mastermind group and believe if you guys
liked this video you want to see more
just like it subscribe to the channel
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you soon don't forget to click here to
subscribe to my newsletter to get
actionable inspiring motivational
believe advice every single week to your
inbox hi I'm Jason G respond so you go
to Rosalyn calm and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period